[Music]
in 1964 President Johnson declared a
national war on poverty so how we done
by one metric not too well in 1966 when
the last major war on poverty programs
were coming online the official census
poverty rate stood at fourteen point
seven percent since then the government
has spent about 20 trillion dollars on
these programs and with all this money
we've only dropped the rate by about one
percentage point to thirteen point five
percent now the official poverty rate is
an imperfect measurement it excludes
some government programs and the modern
comforts that capitalism and innovation
have brought to everyone up and down the
income distribution but America wasn't
just trying to make poverty a little
less miserable to endure we were trying
to make poverty more escapable if more
Americans had been able to escape
poverty and earn their own success we
would see a lot more progress in the
official poverty rate that's why the war
on poverty has been a moral failure we
need to make poverty not just easier to
bear but easier to escape to learn more
about how to help Americans escape
poverty check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you want ati scholars to
cover in 60 seconds